now in china the government is not only
cracking down on muslims but on other
religions as well as it pushes to assert
communist ideology buddhist temples have
been closed or demolished
while a campaign has been launched to
destroy hundreds of statues of buddha
the destruction of the giant guan yin
buddha has drawn
international condemnation as we hear
now from correspondent matthias berlinga
liu ming is a devout buddhist liu is not
his real name
he's afraid of repercussions in his
hometown of
xi'an buddhists have come under pressure
from the government
since they started protesting against
the destruction of a buddhist site on
the outskirts of the city
a three-phased statue of guanyin the
deity of mercy in chinese buddhism
is being demolished
suddenly the government sends the statue
off
they are doing works inside but they
have not told anyone about the reasons
for the destruction
it's left us buddhists and those who
worship the goddess guanyin
inside and outside china quite
bewildered
the three three-phased guanine and an
adjacent monastery were built in 2002
when a company donated the giant statue
to the buddhist community
made of white jade it quickly became
famous
i am trying to get a look at the site
the statue is located in a mountainous
region about an
hour's drive from the city center
the decision to build the statue here in
these mountains was not a coincidence
buddhism has a long history here
this area is something like the cradle
of chinese buddhism
many of the buddhist classics were first
translated from sanskrit into chinese
in monasteries located in this area
as we approach the statue we see
security guards posted at the roadside
stopping and taking pictures of the
demolition is strictly prohibited
the government does not want these
images to spread on social media
we can only film out of the car window
it is unclear how far the demolition has
already gone
activists have written to the government
and campaigned on social media to save
the statue
buddhist associations as far away as
malaysia
have protested against its demolition
but to no avail
xi'an is an ancient capital of china
tourists from all over the world come to
see its historic sites
including its buddhist heritage but in
recent years
the government has pushed for a revival
of communist ideology
even inside datsun temple a world famous
buddhist heritage site
a sign reminds visitors to uphold
socialist
values
it's not only buddhism but also
christianity
and islam the chinese government is
putting immense pressure on religions
buddhism is treated more leniently
because the government considers it to
be more in line with their norms
but i've witnessed myself the pressure
they're putting on buddhist temples
and that activity is increasing
temples have been forced to cancel
religious events
monasteries have had some of their
buildings demolished
experts estimate that the three-phased
buddha
is just one of up to 800 statues that
have been destroyed in recent years
that story from correspondent matthias
berlinga he joins us from beijing now
for more on this story hamatias
why are we seeing this push now to
destroy these buddhist symbols
we've seen a push for communist ideology
for the ideology of the communist party
in the past few
years we've seen a hardening of the
ideological line within the party
and a great uh push for uh their
ideological
ideology in public discourse so religion
is always
of course something that is in
competition with this ideology that is
atheist and the communist party member
must uh promise to be an atheist cannot
be
member of any religious organization in
theory at least
and uh so what we've seen recently is
that displays of uh spirituality
of religion especially recently like
these 800 buddha statues recently
erected uh the statues uh
uh are being uh torn down are being
demolished uh
to to to to make religion less visible
in the public
other religions as well matthias right i
mean there's also pressure on uh
the countries muslims and christian
minorities aren't there
yes there is and the pressure on them is
a lot higher
especially in the western region of
xinjiang where there are distinct muslim
minorities the uyghurs and the kazakhs
pressure on them is very high praying
can get you into an internment camp
there
but there's also pressure on other
muslim groups muslim groups that are not
in the focus of the authorities because
of their ethnicity
but on their display of religion for
example mosques have been destroyed
or have been remodeled if they were
built in an oriental style in a middle
eastern style they had to tear down some
of these features and replace them with
chinese features
and churches had their crosses removed
there has been pressure on christian
communities
also on a newly established christian
communities mostly protestant
communities where pastors have been
arrested but also on the traditional
christian
communities that are found in some of
the locations
in the countryside the communist party
is pushing forward
with its ideology and it's pushing back
any value system that might compete with
them
and these religions especially
christianity and islam that are for
seen as foreign religions are under huge
pressure what do you think the chinese
government is hoping to gain from
repressing this
religious freedom
power power over discourse in in in the
community power
over what people think what people at
least are allowed to publicly
think uh being a buddhist will not
get you to jail but they do not want
this
buddhist faith displayed as they would
have allowed it 20 years ago
okay correspondent matthias bilinga
reporting there from beijing thank you
so much
you